in the last few videos we evaluated this
line integral for this path right over
here by using stoke's theorem by
essentially saying that it's equivalent
to a surface integral of the curl of the
vector field dotted with the surface
what i want to do in this video is to
show that we didn't have to use stoke's
theorem that we could have just
evaluated this line integral and the
thing to keep in mind is in this case
it's it's kind of a toss up which one is
actually simpler to do but stoke's
theorem is valuable because sometimes if
you're faced with the line integral it's
simpler to use stoke's theorem and
evaluate the surface integral or
sometimes if you're faced with the
surface integral it's simpler to use
stoke's theorem and evaluate the line
integral so let's try to figure let's
try to figure out this line integral and
hopefully we're going to get the same
answer if we do everything correctly so
the first thing we want to do is find a
parameterization for our path right over
here this intersection of the plane y
plus z is equal to two and essentially
you can imagine this hollow pipe that
intersects the x y axis at the unit
circle that goes up and down forever and
we get this path right over here with
this orientation and since we're only
since we're only parameterizing a path
it's only going to deal with one
parameter and so let's think about it a
little bit we've done this many times
before but it doesn't hurt to go through
the exercise again so that is our y-axis
this is our x-axis
that is our x-axis and the the x and
y-values are going to take on every
value on the unit circle and then the
z-value is going to tell us how far
above the unit circle we need to be to
actually be on this path so x and y are
going to take on all the values on the
unit circle
and we've done that many times before
the easiest way to think about that is
let's introduce a parameter called theta
let's introduce a parameter called theta
this essentially measures the angle with
the positive x-axis and theta we're just
going to sweep it all around all the way
around the unit circle so theta is going
to go between 0 and 2 pi so 0 is less
than theta which is less than or equal
to
2 pi
and in that situation x is just going to
be this is just the unit circle
definition of trig functions it's just
going to be equal to cosine of theta
y is going to be sine of theta
and then z how high we have to go we can
use this constraint to help us figure it
out y plus z is equal to 2 or we could
say that z is equal to 2 minus y and if
y is sine theta then z is going to be
equal to 2 minus
2 minus sine theta and so we're done
that's our parameterization if we want
to write it as a position vector
function we could write
r
which is going to be a function of theta
is equal to cosine of theta i
plus sine of theta j
plus
two minus sine of theta to minus sine of
theta k
and now we're ready to at least attempt
to evaluate this line integral we need
to figure out what f dot dr is and do
that we need to figure out what d r is
we just have to remind ourselves dr is
the same thing as d r
d theta
times d theta which is equal to so if
you take the derivative of this with
respect to theta derivative of cosine
theta is negative sine theta
negative sine theta i derivative of sine
theta is cosine theta plus cosine theta
j and derivative 2 minus sine theta is
going to be negative cosine theta
negative cosine
theta
k and then all of that times we still
have this d theta to worry about this is
d r d theta and then we have let me
write this down so then we still have to
write our
d
theta just like that and now we're ready
to take the dot product of f with dr so
let's think about this a little bit f
dot dr
f
f dot i'll write dr in this color f dot
dr
is going to be equal to
so we look first at our i components we
have negative y squared times negative
sine of theta that's going to be well
the negatives are going to cancel out so
you're going to get or
so you're going to get y squared times
sine theta
y squared
sine theta that's from the i component
plus now we're going to have x times
cosine theta
plus
x times cosine theta
x times cosine theta and then we're
going to have plus z squared times
negative cosine theta so that's going to
be negative z squared
negative z squared times cosine theta
times cosine
theta and then all of that times d theta
all of that business
times d theta and if we're actually
going to evaluate the integral and now
we have it in kind of our we have it if
we're going to evaluate it over that
path that we care about now we have it
in our theta domain so we could just say
this is a simple integral from theta
going from 0 to 2 pi actually we're not
fully in our theta domain just yet we
still have it expressed in terms of y
x's and z so we have to express those in
terms of theta so let's do that so
that's going to be equal to
the integral from 0 to 2 pi
and actually let me give myself some
more space because i have a feeling this
might take up a lot of horizontal real
estate this is going to be the integral
from 0 to 2 pi
y squared well y is just sine theta so
it's going to be sine squared theta
times another sine theta so this is
going to be sine cubed theta let me
write it in a new color or in blue so
this is sine squared theta times another
sine theta theta this is going to be
sine cubed theta
sine
cubed
theta let me color code it so that's
sine cubed theta put some parentheses
here and then x is x is cosine theta
times the cosine theta
so this is going to be plus cosine
squared theta
and then z squared this is actually
going to get a little bit involved so
let's think about it what z squared is
i'll do it up here
z squared is just going to be
4
minus what is this 4 minus 4
sine
theta
plus
sine squared theta plus sine squared
theta and so we're going to take it's
going to be negative z squared times
cosine theta so negative z squared is
going to be equal to
negative 4
plus 4 sine
theta minus sine squared theta so that's
negative z squared and we're going to
multiply that times cosine theta
now i'll do it in orange so this whole
all of this business right over here is
going to be equal to
cosine theta times cosine theta times
all of this
cosine theta times all of this right
over here so it's going to be negative 4
cosine theta
negative 4
negative 4
cosine theta
plus 4
cosine theta sine theta
plus 4 cosine theta
sine
theta and then minus
cosine
theta sine squared theta sine squared
theta and looks like we're done at least
for this step d
d
theta and so now we just have to
evaluate this integral so we saw
actually setting up our final integral
getting to a simple one-dimensional
definite integral is actually much
simpler in this case but the actual
integral we have to evaluate is a little
bit more complicated we might have to
break out a few of our trig identity
tools in order to solve it properly but
we can solve it but i'll leave you there
in the next video we'll just work on
actually evaluating this integral